[Music]
curious george the beloved children's
book character is a mischievous monkey
whose inquisitiveness gets him in all
kinds of trouble
but before he reached global fame george
started as a drawing in the basket of a
jury-rigged bicycle escaping the nazis
it's 1935 in rio de janeiro brazil
jewish german artists and newlyweds
margaret waldstein and hans reiersbach
were living in an apartment with two pet
monkeys that were always causing trouble
on their honeymoon in paris hans and
margaret fell in love with the city and
decided to move there they spent the
next four years writing and illustrating
children's books
one character was inspired by their pets
in brazil a monkey named fifi
but world war ii was underway and in may
1940 nazi germany crossed into france
with their sights set on paris
hans and margaret planned to escape to
new york on a ship leaving from lisbon
portugal but there were no more trains
out of paris
after a desperate search for
transportation they finally found a
bicycle store that was nearly empty
hans had to improvise so he bought spare
parts and cobbled together two makeshift
bicycles
the next morning hans and margaret
loaded their bicycles with as much as
they could carry including of course
their manuscripts for the adventures of
fifi
they peddled south for four full days to
the nearest working train station
finally arriving in lisbon to board a
ship to rio de janeiro
from rio hans margaret and fifi were
able to safely board a ship to new york
it was here that they published fifi's
first book but decided to give him a new
more american name
george
curious george
after the war hans and margaret became
u.s citizens happily living out their
days in the states
and george his story isn't over the
little monkey has sold 75 million books
has been translated into over 15
languages and has his own tv show and
three full-length movies
but most importantly he continues to
delight curious children around the
world
[Music]
you